[Musik]
es ist die angst in den gesichtern von
kindern von familien in den bunkern in
israel in tel aviv in den straßen dort
die angst vor immer neuen
raketeneinschlägen der hamas das also
ist wieder alltag in israel schauen sie
nicht weg schauen sie dahin vor allem
jetzt da wir diesen hass gegen israel
mittlerweile auch immer wieder auf den
straßen deutschlands erleben was tun
gegen all diesen israel-hass die
richtigen fragen jetzt bei bild und dazu
begrüße ich jetzt herzlich an diesem
sonntagabend live bei bild den
israelischen botschafter in deutschland
yoram iii star darauf ich grüße sie
herzlich danken den vielen dank herr
botschafter mittlerweile mehr als 3000
raketen die von der hamas auf der
israelischen seite eingeschlagen sind in
ihrem land in ihrem staat schildern sie
uns einmal etwas über die angst in ihrem
land unter den familien die kinder
eltern und ihre kinder innerhalb von 10
bis 15 sekunden in die wohnung und
manchmal müssen sie das alleine machen
weil ihre ehemänner reservisten sind und
das ist etwas das wirklich großen druck
auf die bürger und bürgerinnen aus legt
und die menschen müssen in einer so
kurzen zeit von dem ersten erklingen der
serien kann schnell in die bunker israel
hat eine große menge an arbeit geleistet
um die bürger und bürgerinnen schützen
zu können und sagt wir eben die menschen
so schnell in die bunker
deswegen sind die zahlen der getöteten
bei uns im land auch so viel niedriger
wir haben auch sehr viel investiert um
diese raketen abfangen zu können auch
mit dem abfangsysteme eisenkuppel das
ist ein sehr ausgefeiltes
verteidigungssystem gegen raketen und
wir haben darüber hinaus auch sehr viel
investiert um auch die quellen dieser
angriffe im gaza lokalisieren zu können
das ist meistens ein teil der strategie
von hamas dass sie die raketen
abschussbasen um unter der
zivilbevölkerung verstecken
das ist sehr komplex und das
herausfinden aber israel versucht
abzuschrecken
und trotzdem sind mehr als 3100 raketen
auf israel bislang abgeschossen würden
und das ist eine ganz grauenvollen
formen des terrors der da über unsere
grenzen kommt von mama sie die quellen
ausfindig machen und ausfindig gemacht
haben und zerstört haben ist ein schritt
getan sind sie zuversichtlich auf diese
weise den raketenbeschuss durch die
hamas stoppen zu können innerhalb der
nächsten tage
wir hoffen dass diese angriffe schnell
neben sie werden nicht sofort das ist
wahrscheinlich eine frage wenigstens von
stunden und wir hoffen dass es sehr bald
beendet wenn der hamas nämlich klar wird
dass beispielsweise heute als sie
ungefähr 200 raketen abgeschossen haben
seit 1 uhr morgens auch noch dass das
noch unterboten wird das ist aber auch
ganz wichtig etwas zu erwähnen dass ihre
zuschauern zuschauern vielleicht nicht
wissen wir schätzen dass 20 bis 30
prozent dieser raketen die tatsächlich
von gaza aus abgefeuert werden auch im
gaza niedergehen
wir wissen ganz sicher dass wenigstens
in einem falle eine dieser raketen neun
palästinensische kinder im gazastreifen
getötet hat das heißt also dass das also
die zahl der angriffe widerspiegelt auf
uns arbeiten werden
wir haben bislang keine anzeichen
gesehen dass die hamas diese zahl zurück
fahren wird oder ist so vollständig
unterbinden wird oder auf einen
waffenstillstand sich einigen gesprächen
haben wir haben sie aktuell
wann es so weit sein könnte dass ihre
bevölkerung ein wenig aufatmen könnten
denn das wird ja möglicherweise die
häufigste frage gerade von familien von
kindern in ihrem land sein wie lange
noch wann hört das auf was ist sie ihre
antwort ist das eine sache an die sie
sich natürlich nie gewöhnen werden aber
die jetzt zum alltag der israelis über
wochen möglicherweise
gehören wird wahrscheinlich nicht über
wochen
und wissen sie das volk in israel ist
ein sehr widerstandsfähiges wir haben
schon früher krisen durchlebt und wir
wissen mit ihnen und wir haben das
häufig erlebt wie es vom frieden den
krieg ungeschlagen ist und wir versuchen
natürlich sicher dass die menschen die
jetzt diese angst dulden müssen dass sie
aber auch den eindruck haben dass wir in
der lage sind die hammers art zu
stricken abzuschrecken und ihre angriff
wenig keiten auch für einen längeren
zeitraum dann zu zerstören es geht nicht
nur um das was man heute verändern kann
sondern auch was man für die vorserie
zukunft verhindern kann und auch im
allgemeinen und das ist ein punkt den
wir gerade versuchen wir versuchen die
angriffs fertigkeiten der hamas
abschlussmöglichkeit für die hamas zu
begrenzen
was kann die europäische union jetzt
beitragen um sie zu unterstützen um
diesen raketenbeschuss der hamas zu
stoppen was sind ihre erwartungen an uns
muss ich sagen dass in den vergangenen
monaten seit montag das heißt seit dem
beginn dieses raketenbeschuss durch die
hamas auf jerusalem als ist schon aussah
als wäre es etwas ruhiger geworden da
muss ich sagen dass wir wirklich ganz
außergewöhnlicher botschaften
unterstützung aus deutschland von
führende politikerinnen und politikern
bekommen haben von der kanzlerin merkel
aber auch vom sprecher der regierung
ernst und auch von heiko maas von der
verteidigungsministerin rkk und heute
früh erst von horst seehofer aber wir
haben auch von allen
in den großen parteien gehört von armin
laschet dem minister in nordrhein
westfalen von annalena baerbock der
vorsitzende der grünen partei und olaf
schulze aus der oft aus der spd wir
haben also von vielen deutschen aus ganz
vielen unterschiedlichen bereichen
diese unterstützung erhalten wir haben
auch viel über die medien und die presse
erfahren und haben dort sehr viel
anteilnahme erfahren und unterstützende
botschaften für uns erhalten und ich
muss sagen dass ich hier wirklich den
eindruck habe dass wenn europa sich
benehmen würde die deutsche politische
führung dass wir eine sehr viel stärkere
stimme in dieser ganzen situation von
vorne diese unterstützenden stimmen die
es in der tat zum glück gibt aus der
politischen führung und von vielen
vielen mehr in diesem land nur diese
stimmen sind meistens nicht gebrüllt
diejenigen die brüllen die brüllend
ihnen an diesem wochenende ganz viel
hass entgegen und diese stimmen diese
menschen die zu tausenden auf die straße
gegangen sind am wochenende die sind
ganz offenbar eben auch ein teil
deutschlands an diesem wochenende
gewesen und wir wir schämen uns für
diese bilder das darf ich ihnen sagen
herr botschafter die sich hier vor allen
dingen auch in berlin abgespielt haben
am wochenende
was sind ihre gedanken gewesen nicht nur
als botschafter sondern als mensch als
sie diese bilder wie wir sie hier sehen
von dieser großkundgebung am gestrigen
samstag in berlin gesehen haben das ist
verstörend diese bilder zu sehen und es
gab auch unglaublich antisemitische
bemerkungen die dort gegrillt worden
sind des roten flaggen verbrannt und
synagogen angegriffen und das hat nichts
mit dieser krise zu tun und diese krise
hat nichts zu tun mit der deutschen
jüdischen gemeinschaft und ich
verurteile jeden angriff auf die
deutsche jüdische gemeinde diese
antisemitischen ausschreitungen ich muss
sagen
allerdings dass auch die deutschen
politischen führungsetagen also in
präsident steine die kanzlerin und
andere sehr sehr eindeutig dieser
antisemitismus der botschafter denn
diese demonstration sind nicht
verhindert worden es gab gestern die
großdemonstration und am nachmittag
heute am heutigen sonntag ist wieder ein
zug hier wenige hundert meter von hier
entfernt in berlin durch kreuzberg durch
mitte gezogen mit denselben parolen und
wieder hass gegen israel des wurde
skandiert hier direkt vor der haustür
quasi tel aviv bombardieren das heißt
was sind diese worte der politik wert
wenn dann gleichzeitig genau das wieder
auf deutschlands straßen passiert nicht
einmal denke ich sollten sie nicht
vergessen dass es auch demonstrationen
gab bei denen oder die unterstützung
israels ausgedrückten oder das ist nicht
nur ein großer meinungs- block in
deutschland der eindeutig antisemitisch
wäre und wie ich gesagt habe gab es
große und eindeutige reaktionen der
deutschen politischen führung auf diese
phänomene aber es gab eben wie gesagt
auch demonstrationen in berlin frankfurt
leipzig die solidarisch mit israel waren
auch am freitagabend gab es
solidaritätsbekundungen mit der
justizminister mit mit der vorsitzenden
der grünen partei annalena baerbock
diese sehr eindeutig und unzweideutig
ihre unterstützung für israel formuliert
hat das heißt ich verwerfe das nicht
dass es hier probleme mit antisemitismus
geht das sollte auch ganz klar
verurteilt werden und zwar genauso wie
auch der abschuss von 3100 raketen auf
israel klar verurteilt werden musste ich
glaube aus diesem standpunkt ist es so
dass die masse der deutschen förderung
an unserer seite steil ist dieser
antisemitismus nicht besonders
besorgniserregend wie wir ihn jetzt
diesen diesen tagen erlebt haben sie
sagen der muss klar verurteilt werden
aber wir brauchen ein rezept dagegen in
deutschland was wir machen mit diesem
antisemitismus offenbar haben wir keine
lösung gefunden damit umzugehen
das ist
etwas was jetzt nicht nur in den
vergangenen tagen entdeckt worden ist
das ist etwas das traurigerweise schon
viele jahre wenn nicht sogar
jahrhunderte in europa verwurzelt war
und es ist offensichtlich nicht so
einfach dann einfach zu sagen dass man
jemanden verhaftet und dass das problem
damit beendet wäre
die die antwort findet sich in bildung
und auch in den bildungsinstituten
höheren bildung religiöse institutionen
kulturelle institutionen müssen hier
eine rolle spielt kinder lernen nicht
nur in der schule sondern auch zu hause
und deswegen ist es ebenso wichtig
darauf hinzuweisen dass kinder natürlich
die erziehung brauchen aber auch deren
eltern
das ist also ein sehr breiter
anstrengung die man unternehmens und man
braucht auch ganz klare gesetzliche
vorgaben die auch umgesetzt werden wenn
menschen diesen linie überschreiten denn
viele die dort demonstriert haben haben
demonstrierten das ist ganz normal in
demokratien dass man friedlich
demonstrieren darf das passiert
natürlich auch israel aber wenn sie eine
gewisse linie überschreiten wenn es
gewalttätig wird ben ist auf ein
antisemitisches wird dann braucht ist
klar der hand bombardieren tel aviv
bombardieren ist keine friedliche wenn
man das kandiert ist es keine friedliche
demonstration mehr
dazu reicht nicht seit 2000 keine
flaschen fliegen dazu müssen keine
steine fliegen
da stimme ich ihnen natürlich über
einzahlen herr botschafter es gilt heute
als friedliche demonstration was heute
hier vor der tür in berlin passiert ist
da lief die polizei ganz friedlich
nebenher aber es wurde eben skandiert
israels und tel aviv bombardieren
es gilt als friedliche demonstration
wissen sie ich habe auch mit
sicherheitsbeauftragten gesprochen die
mich kontaktiert haben und die haben mir
versichert dass sie alles tun werden
diese phänomene zu unterbinden und diese
art von demonstrationen die auch
gewalttätig sind und hasserfüllt sind
unterbunden werden sollen wo zum
beispiel israelische flaggen verbrannt
wäre und ich nehme sie beim wort und ich
hoffe dass wir weiter diese
anstrengungen unternommen werden um das
zu verhindern werden sie in der lage
sein alles zu verändern das weiß ich
nicht aber wir sollten hier eine gewisse
erwartungen haben das ist also wirklich
größere anstrengungen gibt um diese
phänomen entgegen zu treten
diese art von hass auch zu unterbieten
dank herr botschafter für das gespräch
wir werden alles tun dass israelis und
juden hier in diesem land nicht in angst
leben müssen und ich wünsche ihnen dass
sie schon bald vor allen dingen familien
und kinder in ihrem land nicht mehr
diesem dauerbeschuss aus dem
gaza-streifen seitens der hamas
ausgesetzt sind und diese angst ja bald
möglicherweise wieder sich legen würde
ich dagegen hat sich für das gespräch
heute abend und wir wollen einmal bei
hamburg lange über die demonstration
bereits gesprochen wir wollen noch
einmal schauen was am wochenende und
zwar in ganz deutschland los war in den
straßen welche dimensionen diese
antisemitischen proteste auf unseren
straßen in deutschland angenommen haben
vor allem den gästen deutschland an
diesem samstagnachmittag israel-hass
judenhass köln rund 800 menschen
demonstrieren gegen israel
es wird versucht eine israel flagge
anzuzünden die polizei lässt ihn hass
protest auf
ähnliche bilder zur selben zeit in
frankfurt
[Musik]
bochum menschen skandieren wir werden
nach jerusalem marschieren
berlin in der hauptstadt gleich 1500
menschen palästinenserflaggen tel aviv
komplettieren wird gerufen kindermörder
israel und inmitten dieser hetze kinder
flaschen fliegen böller werden gezündet
die polizei löst die eskalierende demo
auf sie muss tränengas einsetzten
fast 100 polizisten werden verletzt
und heute ging es weiter mit all den
hass bilder wenige meter von unserem
studio entfernt wieder mehrere hundert
menschen mit offenem hass gegen israel
[Musik]
ja israel tel aviv bombardieren das war
erst vor wenigen stunden hier wenige
meter entfernt vom studio auf diesen
straßen berlins heute und wie gesagt
schockierende eindrucksvolle bilder die
uns dort aus vielen größeren und
kleineren städten in deutschland
erreicht haben am gestrigen tag darüber
müssen wir sprechen unter anderem mit
bayerns innenminister joachim herrmann
heute abend mit der israelischen politik
beraterin melodie so coverage mit
alexander graf lambsdorff dem
fdp-experten und mit jürgen trittin den
grünen außenexperte grüße sie alle
herzlich an diesem abend hermann würde
ich gerne anfangen was wie kann das
überhaupt wie konnte das überhaupt
passieren dass am gestrigen tag so viele
tausende menschen in deutschland solche
parolen skandieren und ganz offen ihren
israel-hass zur schau tragen
ich finde diese bilder und auch die töne
die damit verbunden sind absolut das
unerträglich und es ist wichtig dass wir
von seiten aller politischen kräfte in
deutschland deutlich machen dass wir so
etwas nie akzeptieren können
das ist aufgabe in der tat auch der
polizei ist das verbrennen der israel
flagge und möglichst zu unterbinden und
wenn das nicht geschafft wurde dann auf
jeden fall solche täter zur rechenschaft
zu ziehen zu identifizieren sie vor
gericht zu stellen
der deutsche bundestag hat vor über
einem jahr dazu extra strafgesetzbuch
geändert seitdem ist auch das verbrennen
einer solchen staatsflagge eindeutig ein
straftatbestand und das verbreiten von
rassistischen hass von hass gegen juden
gegen israel ist als solche auch
strafbar
das muss konsequent vollzogen werden
hier werden offensichtlich man hier in
den usa scheinbar gewaltfreie angemeldet
und dann präsentieren sie sich doch ganz
anders
ich kann hier aus bayern den einzelnen
abläufe nicht
beurteilen aber sie haben ja auch ein
bild geweigert das hier in nordrhein
westfalen schon auch in einem fall
konsequent eine demo dann aufgelöst
wurde und so muss man darauf konsequent
handeln wenn ihr verbotene dinge
passieren wenn hier letztendlich brutale
hass verbreitet wird dann muss so eine
demonstration auch beendet werden das
demonstrationsrecht die meinungsfreiheit
die uns unheimlich wichtig ist unser
plan
die darf nicht missbraucht werden zu
blanken judenhass und zu solcher
wirklich intoleranten propaganda auch
wenn sie die frage herr alexandria von
amsdorf es ist nicht so richtig
überraschend glaube ich für niemanden in
der runde dass es solches gedankengut in
tausenden köpfen in den großstädten gibt
nun wussten wir alle dass es
demonstrationen geben wird an diesem
sonntag wie konnte es trotzdem passieren
dass all diese demonstrationen auf diese
weise auch stattgefunden haben und all
diese israel hetze ja zur schau zur
schau getragen werden konnte
ich glaube das liegt einfach daran dass
unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung dem demonstrationsrecht
einen enorm hohen stellenwert einräumt
der freien meinungsäußerung in enorm
hohen stellenwert einräumt und wir als
demokraten manchmal auch ertragen müssen
denn meinungen kundgetan werden die uns
überhaupt nicht passen nur eines ist
klar aufruf zu gewalt
antisemitische hassreden das ist keine
meinung mehr da handelt es sich
tatsächlich das hat herr herrmann eben
richtig gesagt und straftaten und das
was mir auch wichtig ist ist dass hier
nordrhein westfalen die polizei wirklich
konsequent vorgegangen ist ich bin heute
abend in bonn in meinem wahlkreis und
war hier vor einigen tagen der synagoge
die angegriffen worden ist wo auch eine
israelische flagge verbrannt worden ist
und ich habe mit der vorsitzenden der
gemeinde hier gesprochen und sie sagt
ihre gemeindemitglieder haben jetzt
angst in die synagoge zu kommen weil sie
nicht mehr wissen ob sie sicher sind und
diese schäden diese folgen angriffe auf
jüdische einrichtungen die er mit dem
staat israel mit der politik überhaupt
gar nichts zu tun haben wo es um freie
glaubens ausbildung geht das ist mir das
ist uns glaube ich allen als demokraten
ebenso wichtig wie das
demonstrationsrecht und deswegen ist
hier jede konsequenz des rechtsstaats
gefordert
menschen die so etwas tun frau sind sie
der auffassung dass wir so lange warten
sollten bis israelische flaggen dann
jedesmal verbrannt werden aber vorher
wird eben skandiert israels kindermörder
israel tel aviv bombardieren und so
weiter und das müssen wir aushalten
selbstverständlich nicht natürlich wäre
es wichtig und richtig gelesen aktiv zu
handeln und mit co aktiv meine ich gar
nicht den beginn der jetzigen eskalation
korrektiv hätte vor jahren eigentlich
schon vor über einem jahrzehnt sein
sollen wenn sich abgezeichnet als ich
damals abgezeichnet hatte durch und
durch radikalisiert viele dieser
demonstrationen vor allem der
organisationen teils auch mit dem iran
verbunden mit der hisbollah mit der
hamas die sich sofort mobilisieren
sobald es irgendeine art eskalation gibt
das hätte schon längst passieren müssen
die worte von herrn minister herren dann
sind wichtig die heute von herrn
seehofer waren klar und deutlich
menschen die das tun werden die schärfe
des gesetzes zu spüren bekommen was ja
eine so klare sprache ist ja auch nicht
so häufig in der deutschen politischen
kommunikationskultur
aber jetzt muss eben dieser schlenker
geschafft werden zwischen der haltung
die unendlich wichtig ist und der aktion
und das ganze auch wirklich in eine neue
realität übersetzen denn so kann es
nicht weitergehen
nicht nur für die juden in deutschland
aber auch für die demokratische substanz
der deutschen gesellschaft herr trittin
was werfen sie sich was werfen sie der
deutschen politik vor dass es zu solchen
demonstrationen aus so von der
demonstration am wochenende kommen
konnte
antisemitismus und rassismus sind keine
meinung
dort wo straftaten begangen werden
müssen die unnachsichtig verfolgt werden
in der landeshauptstadt wo ich meinen
barcas in göppingen habe in der
landeshauptstadt von niedersachsen an
novartis am wochenende drei demos
gegeben eine demonstration der
ausdrücklich der solidarität israels und
dem friedlichen zusammenleben gefahren
werden
eine von
demonstration und eine
pro-palästinensische demonstration die
lange zeit friedlich geblieben ist und
als sie dann auszuarten drohte hat die
polizei das mit nachdruck unterbunden
zwar erfolgreich und genau so stelle ich
mir einen rechtsstaat vor er garantiert
die meinungsfreiheit aber eher bei
kindern kraft hatten und in diesem sinne
fand ich das für den bereich den ich
jetzt über blicke in diesem fall erstmal
eine gute botschaft aber nicht dass es
nur eine gute botschaft ist herr trittin
wir schauen wir uns noch mal ganz kurz
an was der regierungssprecher am freitag
gesagt hat in der
regierungspressekonferenz antisemitische
grund gehen um wird unsere demokratie
nicht dulden
dem würde niemand von uns widersprechen
hat gesagt antisemitische kundgebung
wird unsere demokratie nicht dulden das
war am tag bevor diese demonstrationen
dann genauso stattgefunden haben herr
herrmann die demonstration soweit ich
das verfolgt habe
solche bilder wie sie sich gerade
gezeigt haben hat es nun in bayern gott
sei dank nicht gegeben dann kann ich
mich hier jetzt sich für unmittelbare
bayerische erlebnissen äußern aber diese
demonstration werden offensichtlich
jahren zunächst einmal als pro
palästinensisch angemeldet das ist als
solches nicht verboten und dann wie herr
trittin gerade gesagt hat dann schlagen
sie um in blanken antisemitismus und
darauf muss man konsequent reagieren
genauso wird beschrieben da muss auch in
eine laufende demonstration wie
irgendwas eingegriffen werden wir müssen
aber natürlich schon auch klartext
sprechen wir uns in den letzten zwei
drei jahren intensiv mit den
verheerenden rechtsextremistischen
anschlägen zb auf die synagoge in alle
beschäftigt und mit den ursachen des
rechtsextremismus über das bekämpfen
müssen was wir jetzt erleben sind
dadurch ganz überwiegend nicht
rechtsextremisten sondern es sind ganz
überwiegend der menschen mit
muslimischem hintergrund die
aufgestachelt zum teil auch von brutalen
reden von präsident erdogan in der
türkei und anderen meinen dass jetzt
diese auseinandersetzung auf deutschen
straßen austragen zu müssen
und das ist natürlich schon ein problem
wir haben
der vergangenheit wiederholt darüber
geredet dass leider antisemitismus nicht
nur aus der rechtsextremistischen seite
kommt sondern zum teil auch von
linksextremen aber ganz offensichtlich
eben auch aus den muslimischen bereich
und da muss man auch ganz deutlich
ansprechen die muslime leben sehr gute
mit unserer religionsfreiheit unseren
respekt unsere toleranz gegenüber ihre
religion aber wir erwarten dass sie
selbst auch diese toleranz gegenüber
juden gegenüber christen gegenüber allen
anderen entsprechend ausüben und das
können wir nicht zulassen dass jemand
mit fanatischer intoleranz unterwegs ist
und da muss man in der tat jetzt auch in
diesen kreis deutlich aufzeigen man muss
die menschen die straftaten begehen
entsprechend vor gericht stellen
aber wir müssen auch an ganz einfach ich
einfordern wer auf dauer in unserem land
leben will der muss genau diese
grundsätze von meinungsfreiheit von
religionsfreiheit von toleranz gegenüber
andersdenkenden auch leben und wer sich
derartig intolerant aufführte dem müssen
die grenzen aufgezeigt werden das heißt
das heißt ganz konkret hermann den satz
noch hinterher das heißt konkret die
einen die einen die einen müssen
natürlich vor gericht gestellt werden
und dann sonst muss man schon auch
deutlich machen da sind offensichtlich
ganze menge menschen nicht wirklich
integriert in unsere
gesellschaftsordnung in das was unsere
verfassung eigentlich ausmacht dass in
öffentlichen massive defizite und da
muss man auch die ebenfalls überprüfen
sind das alles leute die schon
daueraufenthaltsrecht haben die deutsche
staatsangehörigkeit haben wenn sie das
nicht haben muss man auch im vertrag
prüfen dass jemand der so intolerant ist
jetzt jedenfalls nicht mehr eingebürgert
wird und dass er wenn die rechtlichen
möglichkeiten gegeben sind auch unser
land verlassen muss weil das ist nicht
das was unsere verfassungsordnung
vorgibt eine lampe ich würde auch gern
auf 1 zu sprechen kommen was der
bayerische innenminister eben
angesprochen hat dass man ja erstmal auf
diejenigen schaut die solche
demonstration anmelden
das klingt erstmal ganz vernünftig und
dann läuft das plötzlich aus dem ruder
ich glaube nicht dass das so ist ehrlich
gesagt weil wir alle haben uns schon
vorbereitet auf ein solches wochenende
an dem es zu solchen eskalation kommen
könnte
das lag auf der hand nach all dem
was an den tagen zuvor auch passiert ist
und spätestens dann heute hätte man das
wissen müssen dass war wie gesagt hier
vor der haustür eine angemeldete
offenbar angemeldete demonstration die
hat stattgefunden nach den ereignissen
von gestern trotzdem hat man sie
stattfinden lassen und trotzdem hat es
wieder diese rufe gegeben das heißt im
grunde haben sie alle die sie beisammen
sitzen gar kein mittel das zu verhindern
dass das morgen wieder vorkommt und am
nächsten wochenende wir schauen zu und
greifen bei straftaten dann ein
also ich glaube das entscheidende ist
dass die sicherheitsbehörden sich sehr
genau anschauen müssen wer meldet
eigentlich diese demonstrationen an sind
dass personen die einschlägig bekannt
sind sind die verknüpft mit
organisationen vereinen die einschlägig
bekannt sind und wenn das der fall ist
dann müssen die auflagen so streng
gemacht werden dass es eben nicht dazu
kommen kann aber ich will hier eines
auch deutlich sagen und ich glaube das
muss man das hat herr herrmann von der
csu gesagt hat der trittin von den
grünen gesagt ich sage dass wir die
liberalen das demonstrationsrecht ist
ein hohes gut sie können das kraft staat
nicht so streng beschneiden dass sie
jede äußerung auf einer solchen
demonstration unterbinden können die
gerichte würden ist dann genehmigen wenn
die verwaltungen ist unter bänden aber
und das ist entscheidend wenn wir anders
rangehen was ich gerade gesagt habe die
einschlägig bekannten anführer von
organisationen fernhalten von solchen
demonstrationen das geht wir haben als
deutsche bundestag den politischen
flügel der hamas in dieser
legislaturperiode auf betreiben der
freien demokraten aber dann anschließend
im breiten konsens zu einer terror
organisation erklärt das war frau cherie
wird für das wissen ein langjähriger
wunsch der israelischen seite und der
war auch berechtigt und nachvollziehbar
gab es in dieser legislaturperiode
hingekriegt wir haben bds für eine anti
zu einer sozusagen erklärt das bds
boykott bei west senken also eine anti
israelische organisationen ebenfalls vom
deutschen bund vom bundes vom bund nicht
mehr unterstützt werden darf weil die
denkstrukturen dort antisemitisch sind
das heißt wir halten schon dagegen aber
er weiß wenn sie so wollen in gewisser
weise haben sie recht sie können in
einem rechtsstaat nicht jede
demonstration unterbinden das geht nicht
gerichte würden das nicht mitmachen ich
will herausfinden wie groß ihre aller
entschlossenheit ist gegen diesen
antisemitismus vorzugehen frau suchen
die entschlossenheit ist offenbar so
groß ein kleines beispiel wenn man so
will aus der stadt hagen dort hat man so
heißt es offiziell um zu deeskalieren in
dieser brenzligen lage im moment vor dem
rathaus die israelische fahne
israelische flagge abgehängt um zu
deeskalieren frau sucher rewitz dieses
bizarre konzept der deeskalation kennen
wir jetzt schon seit vielen vielen
jahren ist erinnert mich so ein bisschen
an die furchtlose an die deeskalation
die manche lehrer versuchen
durchzuführen ihren schuhen wenn
studenten oder schüler sie damit
bedrohen wenn du holocaust durchgenommen
wird man ihnen das nicht passt und dann
um eben zu deeskalieren oder sogar nicht
zu provozieren so hört sich das von
verschiedenen lehrern wird man das thema
einfach gelassen genau dasselbe ist das
jetzt hier also anstatt wirklich hier
rückgrat zu zeigen zu den grundwerten
der deutschen demokratie zu stehen und
dabei als teil davon auch zur jüdischen
gemeinschaft und zum staat israel die
flagge runterziehen das ist ein solches
armutszeugnis
ich würde mich schämen an die anstelle
und würde so rasch wie möglich diese
flagge wieder hochziehen und ich würde
es selbstbewusstsein tun
das ist das gute deutschland das wir
kennen dass wir den vielen statements
der politischen führer gehört haben wir
letzten tagen und ich wünschte dass es
über schwappt auch auf die
kommunalpolitik und dann hoffentlich
auch auf die straße den stimmt dass
möglicherweise sogar dass das zeigen der
israelischen flagge in deutschland
zumindest in einigen teilen ein
sicherheitsrisiko ist ich wünsche mir
dass nicht ich habe vorhin darauf
hingewiesen wie man sie haben die frage
stellt man mit so etwas umgehen in dem
moment wo eine demo oder ein verhalten
die rechtlichen grenzen die wir in
deutschland haben überschreitet nicht
die polizei einschreiten
und ich habe das bewusst mit einem
beispiel aus hannover begleitet wo der
dafür vorgesehene innenminister
verantwortliche innenminister
bekanntermaßen nicht meiner partei
sondern der spd angehört dort ist so
vorgegangen
das fand ich erst mal ein gutes vorgehen
und denkt da können sie mal auch
zustimmen verweise das zweite man kann
sich nicht auf so einen
opportunistischen weg begeben
ich finde das unerträglich aus
deeskalation gründen auch so etwas zu
verzichten
ich fand es im gegenteil er ein stück
auch bürgerlichen selbstbewusstseins das
als menschen versucht haben in diesen
tagen die ihn am rathaus pankow in
berlin hängen der israelische fahne mit
müll abzufackeln aufmerksame bürger das
unterbunden haben
also ich finde wir müssen auch die dinge
so zu sagen in ihrer relation sehen und
ich warne davor zum beispiel muslime
unter generalverdacht zu stellen ich
würde schon darauf hinweisen dass der
zentralrat der muslime in deutschland
sehr früh sehr deutlich sich an diesen
attacken distanziert hat und
ausdrücklich darauf hingewiesen hat dass
kann israel die werden nicht alle
positionen der israelischen regierung
nur werden sie nicht machen aber genau
diese grenze zum antisemitismus nicht
überschritten werden darf
offensichtlich würde ich auch hier dazu
raten zu differenzieren und genau hin zu
ja das tun wir auch allerdings macht das
der zentralrat der muslime offenbar
nicht mit ganz ganz großem einfluss wenn
ich die demonstration vom wochenende
sehe und das einschreiten wenn es hier
darum geht eine israelische flagge zu
entfernen oder zu verbrennen
ich halte das für unsere aufgabe ehrlich
gesagt für unsere eine
selbstverständlichkeit mit dem beispiel
aus banken bewusst hingewiesen
da er halte das für eine
selbstverständlichkeit wir versuchen den
antisemitismus zu ergründen auch was ist
im moment ja ihre idee woher kommt
dieser antisemitismus den wir so präsent
gesehen haben an diesem wochenende wie
seit ganz vielen jahrzehnten andere
sagen wie seit 1945 nicht mehr von mir
geht es natürlich um diese
auseinandersetzung zwischen der
arabischen welt zwischen den
palästinensern
und dem staat israel und wir erleben
hier natürlich eine gerade im letzten
jahr auch zunehmende fanatisierte wieder
auch in teilen der muslimischen welt die
stimme eintritt hinzu das darf man nicht
verallgemeinern es ist keineswegs so
dass alle muslime schon gar nicht alle
muslime in unserem land so denken aber
es gibt eben diese radikalen
erscheinungen als sind wiederholt auf
gruppierungen von islamisten ja in
unserem land verboten worden
bro seehofer hatte erst vor kurzem
wieder eine solche islamistische
organisation verboten und man hört dass
zum teil auch manche dem aus im moment
jetzt eine gewalttätige reaktion auch
gut so dann über dieses verbot
letztendlich zum ausdruck bringen
damit müssen wir uns auseinandersetzen
da muss man aber klar sagen ich bin der
festen überzeugung die überwältigende
mehrheit der gesamtbevölkerung in
unserem land hält es für richtig dass
hier gegen solche radikalen elemente
vorgegangen wird
und dann darf man auch sich nicht irre
machen lassen das ist unerträglich was
da manchmal auch den straßen sich
abspielt aber es ist eben nicht die
mehrheit der bevölkerung in unserem land
die so denkt ganz im gegenteil
da muss man konsequent entsprechend auch
einschreiten und ich will ausdrücklich
ja auch sagen weil das beispiel von
ihnen genannt worden ist dass da eine
kommune zur deeskalation die fahne
eingezogen hat das ist natürlich falsch
ich kenne erfreulicherweise auch eine
ganze reihe von kommunen zum beispiel in
bayern die ausdrücklich aus solidarität
mit israel
diese fahne aufgezogen haben wir haben
auch ein beispiel weil im landkreis
würzburg vor zwei tagen da ist ein
echtes diese fahne geklaut worden und
dann hat der landrat ganz muss am
nächsten tag erneut eine israelische
fahne aufgezogen sich also nicht
weggeduckt und gesagt dann lassen müssen
lieber sein sondern ganz bewusst gesagt
ja dann wenn die nächsten seiner
geklauter dann ziehe ich wieder neu eine
fahne auf wir lassen uns da nicht davon
abbringen dass wir unsere solidarität
mit israel bekundet
ich glaube diese positiven dinge müssen
wir auch wahrnehmen wir müssen
konsequent gegen die extremisten
vorgehen
aber wir müssen auch schon feststellen
dass es auch sehr sehr viel solidarität
mit israel und auch mit den jüdischen
gemeinden
da stellen wir auch fest nur löst das
unser problem noch nicht und auch die
verurteilung die sie alle machen die
sind ganz wichtig auch an diesem abend
heute aber die lösen leider unser
gemeinsames problem alle noch nicht
verrät die vorsitzende der bonner
jüdischen gemeinde sagte sind vorwiegend
überwiegend junge arabische männer die
im moment dieses problem des
antisemitismus in deutschland auf die
straße bringen dass es deren analyse wie
geht ihre zur statistik gibt es seit
vielen jahren eben dieses wissen
geschehen ist es die mehrheit der
muslime die zugewandert sind und
radikalisiert wurden oder es schon waren
von haus aus oder eben doch die rechte
die auch immer stärker in die mitte
überschwappt ich würde sagen dass dieses
mosaik der antisemiten
das steht ja auch fest aus welchen
teilen das besteht und und das zu
bekämpfen muss auch nicht neu erfunden
werden dass der antisemitismus nicht
erst bei der haspa rolle bei der
demonstration anfängt sondern eben schon
bei der erziehung im schulsystem zu
hause in den satelliten fernsehen aus
der türkei al jazira oder sonst wurde
das iranische fernsehen dass diese
jugendliche über satellit in ihrem
eigenen wohnzimmer empfangen das
gefülltes von den widerlichsten ag
semitischen hetzen aber auch
antidemokratischen anti westlichen werte
verletzungen
das sind dinge die müssen proaktiv
gestoppt werden weil wenn das einfach so
weiterläuft und hingenommen wird
und wenn es hingenommen wird dass das
gesetz eine frage der publikation des
beziehungsweise es in ordnung ist gegen
dieses gesetz zu verstoßen
dann hat es verheerende folgen uns wie
gesagt in erster linie für die deutsche
gesellschaft selber
sie haben gerade versuche rivic kinder
und die erziehung angesprochen also es
wird sozusagen teilweise der
antisemitismus zu hause eben schon
gelehrt das sind bilder die wir am
wochenende eben auch gesehen haben dass
dort eben auch ganz gezielt die kinder
eben mitgebracht wurden und dort eben
auch entsprechende parolen mit auf die
stirn geschrieben wurden oder als
plakate mit gegeben wurden das heißt
wenn wir diese bilder sehen macht
ja auch gleichzeitig das so schwer
dieses problem zu lösen herr lambsdorff
wenn wir wissen dass stammt eben tief
verwurzelt aus dem elternhaus was haben
wir was haben sie da entgegen zu setzen
ich glaube das was versuche ich gerade
gesagt hat ist richtig aber dann muss
man sich fragen wie hält man denn
dagegen ganz konkret wenn es gerade um
satelliten fernsehen geht und ein punkt
den wir immer wieder fordern als fdp ist
dass wir der deutschen welle endlich
erlauben ihre wirklich hervorragenden
und demokratisch einwandfreien
fremdsprachigen programme auch in
deutschland auszustrahlen
wir haben ein wunderbares arabisches
programm der deutschen welle das wird in
berlin und bonn produziert und es wird
in die ganze arabische welt ausgestrahlt
ist er extrem beliebt und ist völlig
einwandfrei was seine werte angeht aber
in deutschland kann man es nicht sehen
und das ist zum beispiel ein angebot das
man diesen familien machen könnte in
denen eben die deutsche sprache noch
nicht verankert ist die arabisch sich
sich informieren und unterhalten lassen
wollen ich bin in der arabischen welt
unterwegs gewesen
der krude teilweise wirklich brutale
antisemitismus der einem da begegnet der
ist mit händen zu greifen und
tatsächlich ist es so wenn sie in länder
fahren wie libyen oder oder ägypten
es ist es ist wirklich der verglichen
damit haben wir hier in deutschland ein
1 1 1 1 grands bares problem dort ist es
völlig entgrenzt aber wir haben hier in
deutschland eine besondere verantwortung
und ich glaube dass das ein ganz
konkreter vorschlag ist nur mal um einen
zu nennen wo wir ein instrument schon
haben als bunt aber wo aus irgendwelchen
rundfunkstaatsvertrags technischen
gründen ist nicht möglich ist dieses
hervorragende angebot hier verfügbar zu
machen ich sehe das ehrlich gesagt nicht
länger ein ein kleiner punkt wie sie
selbst sagen der kauf lamster vertreten
was haben sie entgegen zu setzen ich
würde behaupten wenn man hier jenseits
unseres studios auf die straße geht nach
kreuzberg beispielsweise nach neukölln
sie werden probleme haben eine mehrheit
für das existenzrecht israels zu finden
auf der straße was haben sie da entgegen
zu setzen gegen diesen gegen diese jahr
tief verankerte meinung gegenüber israel
eine ganz beharrliche es ist die
sicherung des existenzrechts israels
grundkonsens der deutschen
das ist ein teil unserer historischen
verantwortung
und dies müssen alle menschen die hier
leben so akzeptieren und da muss man in
einer beharrlichkeit auf diesem punkt
auch bei aachen
und ich würde im übrigen die idee von
graf lambsdorff über satellit oder sei
es über internet streaming diese
programme besser und auch im inland
verfügbar zu machen halte ich für klug
jetzt sprechen wir schon über
berichterstattung der lassen sie mir
einen punkt machen frau sucher rewitz
wir waren in den vergangenen stunden
vergangenen tagen ab und zu etwas
irritiert auch über die
berichterstattung der tagesschau die
immer wieder über eine gewalteskalation
auf beiden seiten spricht und gestern
über die demonstrationen geschrieben hat
demonstrationen gegen eskalation im
nahen osten und da kamen dann auch
frauen wie sie beispielsweise zur wort
mit entsprechenden hassparolen auf dem
plakat daneben als sie war recht
eindeutig zuzuordnen anhand ihres plakat
es wurde dort interviewt frau so fit wie
nehmen sie diese berichterstattung war
ich setzte noch eins drauf ich sah ein
interview vom zdf mit einer dame einer
deutschen dame die ein schild seiner
hand hält auf dem stand das ist ein
holocaust in gaza und die frau wurde
interviewt wie ein normaler
ernstzunehmender mensch es wurde
kommentarlos hingenommen dieses poster
und da sind wir beim anfang des problems
ich befürchte dass die
medienberichterstattung über viele jahre
ob bewusst oder unbewusst intention irrt
oder und n10 jetzt er ist viel feuer
hier sehr viel öl ins feuer werfen denn
von verzerrungen der situation zu
halbwahrheiten in zufälliger auslassen
des historischen kontext und der
kausalitäten da haben wir wirklich das
gesamte programm in einem großen fall
natürlich nicht in allen aber in einem
großen teil der deutschen medien und
wenn man überhaupt sich nicht auskennt
aus irgendeinem persönlichen hintergrund
weil man zum beispiel zum beispiel man
in israel war oder jüdische freunde hat
und einfach so ein bisschen mehr
hintergrund mitbekommen
der wirklich nur über die medien ein
bild von israel macht sieht israel
höchstwahrscheinlich als adressat ohr
bekommt egal egal wie viele raketen die
hamas auf israel schießt hört er immer
erst vom angriff israels auf den
gazastreifen und oft gar nicht mal als
rückschlag oder reaktion sondern einfach
schießt jetzt die israelische armee auf
den gazastreifen
man hört wenn es um die israelische
seite geht sehr viel an abstraktionen
soldaten immer diese unterstellungen
also im sinne von die armee laute armee
ist das was passiert wenn dem auf der
palästinensischen seite
das ganze schon sehr viel emotionaler
persönlicher auch in der sprache und im
bild vor allem sehr viel
emotionalisierende dargestellt wird das
ist jetzt keine persönliche subjektive
interpretation von mir dazu gibt es über
die letzten zehn 15 jahre zig
verschiedene studien die das detailliert
analysiert haben
und das spielt eine wichtige rolle weil
vor allem die mit ich ja natürlich nicht
direkt über die qualitäten berlin mitte
mit dach so tappe tag liest sich nolens
volens höchstwahrscheinlich
antisemitische ressentiments entwickeln
einmal um zuzuordnen von wo sie uns
geradezu schalten frau sue karibik sie
stehen auf der terrasse oder auf dem
balkon eines größeren hauses in tel aviv
wir haben einmal das kenntlich gemacht
auf der karte wo ungefähr sich das
befindet um unsere zuschauer mitzunehmen
und ganz in der nähe hat in den
vergangenen tagen auch raketeneinschläge
gegeben das heißt auch sie haben die
erfahrung natürlich gemacht mit
raketenalarm und eben dann auch
einschlägen ein video das sie uns
geschickt haben das stammt von wan frau
so karibik schreiben was man da sieht
sie sehen hier den direkten einschlag
einer rakete wahrscheinlich eine
asiatische 250 rakete
in einem parkhaus in ramazzotti oder pro
minute vor sachschaden alle alle
menschen waren zu dem zeitpunkt bereits
im bunker ich war zu dem zeitpunkt es
war natürlich hier aufgrund der
unmittelbaren nähe ein sehr lauter knall
es war mir ganz klar dass das etwas ist
was eine andere art explosion also nicht
nur deren sohn der die hamas raketen
abschießt das sind immer so dumm für
zwar laut aber dunklen als er aus der
ferne wenn man das mal so unmittelbar
dass ich mich in der tat auf meine zwei
schlafenden mann nicht mehr schlafen
kinder geworfen habe in der offenburger
das erleben darf ich fragen wie sie das
leben ihre kinder schauen wir das erste
mal während dem 2014 gaza krieg war
meine kleine tochter ein halbes jahr und
und hat die meisten nächte in der zeit
im bunker verbracht und damals war es
einfach weil ich sie einfach eintragen
konnte und die hat natürlich ein sechs
monate altes kind nichts mitbekommen
es ist jetzt herzzerreißend
möglicherweise zu sehen wie diese
glücklichen kinder die normalerweise nur
strahlen und witze machen
verängstigt sind sich nicht trauen aus
dem bunker rauszukommen die battle
nämlich an geschlafen schon dort eine
woche im bunker ich kann mir nicht eine
sekunde dort alleine lassen
in den ersten tagen war ich alleine mit
ihnen weil mein mann in die reserve
eingezogen wurde und sie fürchten sich
sogar wenn ich auch nur eine minute raus
gehe und den start zu bringen oder sonst
wo ein glas wasser zu holen das heißt
und das sind nicht natürlich nicht nur
meine kinder da sind alle kinder die
diesen raketen seien ausgesetzt sind und
was mir wirklich das herz zerbricht
obwohl es mir doch vor schon bewusst war
aber nie so stark wie jetzt wo ich sehe
wie meine kinder darunter leiden
das sind die kinder im süden israels mit
raketen
tag für tag ausgesetzt sind und sprechen
leben kann us-raketen die meist eben
nicht in den medien erscheinen die
einfach zu tröpfeln und tropfen und die
seele und die psyche dieser kinder und
gesamte familientag betrag zerstören
das sind kinder die haben 15 sekunden
zeit um sich in sicherheit zu bringen in
den bunker wenn die sirene los geht's
wir sind kinder die duschen nicht normal
die g nicht einmal auf die toilette die
doch nicht normal weil sie ständig mit
dieser terror angst leben
um diese angst um ihr eigenes leben weil
es einfach ständig passiert dass man es
nicht schafft in den bunker und das ist
ein direkter anschlag gibt und wir haben
alleine jetzt in den letzten tagen durch
diese 3000 raketen der hamas elf
todesopfer und das ist nur todes nur elf
sind und damit beende ich meine antwort
ist ein immenses brille durch diesen
song den wir haben und es ist auch kein
zug weil es ist wirklich dieser geniale
innovationsgeist der an diesem dieser
abwehrraketen gearbeitet hat und dafür
sorgt dass hier nacht einigermaßen
einigermaßen sicher schlafen können und
ist eben nur elf todesopfer und kein
nation nationales blutbad geworden ist
was der mafia zu hören wie wer wird
schon an dieser stelle möchte einmal
unsere runde noch erweitern um oliver
franco wird sterns zugeschaltet ist aus
tel aviv er franco wünsche ich grüße sie
ganz herzlich
das schön dass sie an dem sehr späten
abend bei ihnen zu hause
nach einer langen schichtarbeit heute
noch mit uns sprechen und zugeschaltet
sind
der franken wird arbeitet als pfleger in
einem altenheim als deutscher pflege an
einem israelischen alten einem klick
dort unter anderem holocaust überlebende
sagen sie uns ganz kurz am anfang
wichtigste frage ist es aktuell ruhig
bei ihnen in bezug auf raketenbeschuss
auf raketenalarm also ich bin jetzt
gerade bei mir daheim nicht in tel aviv
im rahmen deiner stadt zwischen tel aviv
und jerusalem spieler ebene jetzt gratis
so ruhig heißt werden kein raketenalarm
räumlich allerdings nur eine dieser
gemischten städte in der nacht zu heute
hier keine raketen der frühschicht hatte
ich im heim des heimischen ramat gan
grenzt direkt östlich von tel aviv an
und dort werde ich morgen und übermorgen
die nacht verbringen warum um die dort
arbeitenden menschen zu unterstützen im
fall von raketenalarm die mehr als 100
bewohnerinnen des heims aus ihren
zimmern aus ihren wohnungen zu holen und
einen
relativ sicheren ort zu bringen
sie haben da so was wie raketen
notdienst sagen sie das heißt sie müssen
extra schicht schieben um diejenigen die
eben nicht mehr schnell oder gar nicht
mehr auf den beinen sind einigermaßen
zumindest in sichere räume zu bringen
innerhalb sehr kurzer zeit genau diese
die belegschaft in der nacht die
angestellten je nach dienst haben sind
nicht sind zu wenige um allem menschen
die im heim leben aus ihren zimmern zu
holen
deswegen übernachten jede nacht weitere
mitarbeiter vom heim im heim in
wohnungen und zimmern die dort frei
sehen
um im fall von einem raketenangriff zur
stelle zu sein und zu helfen
ich habe schon gesagt sie pflegen dort
unter anderem auch holocaust überlebende
in ihrem altenheim wir haben diese
sendung begonnen mit den bildern von
demonstrationen hier aus berlin von
eindeutig antisemitischen
demonstrationen ist das bei ihnen im
altenheim ein thema wird darüber
gesprochen kommen diese bilder dort an
altenheim in dem ich arbeite das sich
übrigens der eltern heim nennt gehört
der vereinigung der israelis
mitteleuropäischer herkunft an das wurde
gegründet für deutsche juden in den 1930
er jahren palästina geflüchtet sind und
dort somit begründet stadt ist und das
sind alles menschen die die juden
diskriminierung verfolgung in
deutschland miterlebt haben und außerdem
es in dem heim viele menschen aus
osteuropäischen ländern die außer der
folge noch die judenvernichtung
miterlebt haben jetzt sehen diese
menschen in den nachrichten und es wird
in jeder nachrichtensendung gezeigt
antisemitische traktion aus london aus
paris und auch aus berlin
und es ist für diese menschen
besorgniserregend es ist schockierend es
ist entsetzlich
und es ist diesen menschen auch nicht zu
erklären warum das
stattfinden kann in deutschland wo lisa
lied mit israel immer wieder als
staatsräson propagiert wird und dann
wird trotzdem geduldet dass auf den
straßen israel und den juden hamas hamas
juden ins gas skandiert wird diese
menschen bekommen das mit und müssen es
mitbekommen
an ihrem lebensabend ich denke allein
das zu bringen diese demonstration zu
verbieten
hermann demonstration verbieten sagte
franco wird auf jeden fall wenn wir
diese berichte von vor ort auch hören
dort aus tel aviv aus einem altenheim
mit holocaust überlebenden sind wir
wirklich laut genug um dagegenzuhalten
tun wir wirklich schon alles
ich glaube schon dass wir sehr deutlich
sind und auch konsequent auftreten auch
unsere polizei ich bin dankbar dass sie
gerade das thema der berichterstattung
auch noch mal angesprochen haben weil
mich in der rat manche nuancen manche
untertöne auch in deutschen
fernsehsender in den letzten tagen auch
schon auch irritiert haben will
ausdrücklich an dieser stelle mal sagen
dass ich großen respekt habe davor dass
die bild zeitung auch in der tradition
von axel springer in den thema
existenzrecht israels und der besonderen
deutschen verantwortung sagte er einen
ganz konsequenten kurs fährt
und das auf aktuell jetzt wieder
deutlich tut auch mit dieser diskussion
heute abend das ist wichtig und da haben
insgesamt alle deutschen medien
natürlich eine große verantwortung
welches bild sie von dieser
auseinandersetzung im nahen osten
vermitteln und welches bild sie auch von
der situation bei uns in deutschland
vermitteln und das ist wichtig da fängt
es nämlich anbeginn er damit um wie
äußern wir uns gibt es da eine falsche
toleranz gegenüber antisemitismus gibt
es eine falsche toleranz gegen der
fanatischen intoleranz
die leute die hier unterwegs sind da
müssen wir immer klar flagge zeigen dann
ist nur konsequent auftreten da darf ist
kein wackeln geben aber ich glaube das
wird jetzt auch deutlich und ich freue
mich über den breiten politischen
konsens der jetzt hier auch in dieser
runde deutlich wird das ist wichtig und
genau das müssen wir auch rüberbringen
damit die davon bin ich überzeugt große
mehrheit der menschen in deutschland die
genau auch so denkt
in der tat auch bemüht hat das in aller
öffentlichkeit zu sagen herr trittin
können sie das für sich für ihre partei
für ihre fraktion auch in anspruch
nehmen dass sie sagen da gibt es kein
wackeln da gibt es keine zwischentöne
bei der frage stehen wir ganz klar aber
das gilt für alle demokratischen
parteien in diesem lande
wir haben uns sehr deutlich dazu bekannt
und wenn ich die diversen erste
mitteilungen übrigens auch die
stellungnahme der regierung an dieser
stelle sehen gibt es hier in deutschland
hierfür einen sehr breiten konsens der
konsens beinhaltet die solidarität mit
israel
die forderung die gewalt das beginnt mit
den raketenangriffen umgehend zu beenden
weil es ist so ja schrecklich wie in tel
aviv wie in jerusalem menschen leiden
kleinen übrigens auch in gaza menschen
auch kinder dort und deswegen halte ich
die forderung nach einem umgehenden ende
der gewalt handlung eine einstellung der
raketenangriffe wie sie unter anderem
un-generalsekretär guter rush wie ist
der deutsche außenminister wies die
deutsche kanzlerin der bundespräsident
heute laut iata für richtig das ist auch
bestandteil dieser haltung von super
witzig sprach gerade von zwischentönen
von einer nahe beide seiten sind doch
aufgerufen jetzt mal zur ruhe zu finden
zu einer waffenruhe zu finden was
empfinden sie bei solchen ja vorsichtig
gesagt zwischentönen er hat mir
wahnsinnig das sagen da ich habe sehr
deutlich gesagt dass
die raketenangriffe beendet werden
müssen ich habe nicht die dinge
gleichgestellt können sie das habe ich
habe ich habe ihnen das nicht in den
mund gelegt herr trittin ich bin
ziemlich auf andere äußerung ich bin
ziemlich unter anderem heute auf eine
äußerung des parteivorsitzenden aber vor
allen dingen auch das spd des spd
parteivorsitzenden und des spd
fraktionsvorsitzenden aus dieser woche
von herrn mütze nicht bei dem nämlich
genau das geschehen ist bei dem nämlich
beides gleich gleichgesetzt wurde frau
so harry
schlimmer noch bayern münchen nicht
wurde nicht nur beides gleich gesetzt
sondern herr mützenich verband setze
oder legitimierte so ein bisschen die
gewalt die antisemitischen aufruf bei
den demonstrationen gegen juden und
meinte jetzt sollte es doch mal zum
barbie israel sollte doch mal einlenken
und zum waffenstillstand greifen
sozusagen damit hier die antisemitischen
ausschreitungen gegen die jugend
deutschland auf wenn also das war sehr
unglücklich
höchst kontraproduktiv ich glaube die
entschuldigung oder klarstellung bleibt
noch aus zu der frage allgemeinen die
berühmte gewaltspirale die berühmte
äquidistanz zwischen der hamas und
israel
die oft in subtiler form sowohl von
politikern als auch in den medien oft
aber auch einfach ganz klar kommuniziert
wird ist eines der großen probleme und
auch eines der ursachen glaube ich viele
viele der ressentiments in der deutschen
gesellschaft bilden wenn man mal
medienkonsumenten und wer heute ist
wirklich wagt bewusst eine
terror-organisation der nicht nur
israelis selbst die bevölkerung
terrorisiert sondern vor allem auch die
eigenen menschen die eigene bevölkerung
terrorisiert wir haben es vorhin gehört
vom botschafter das hat reuters vor
einigen tagen veröffentlicht dass ein
drittel der hamas-raketen im
gazastreifen landes über neun kinder
wurden palästinensische kinder wurden
bei einem angriff der gehalt der der der
hamas-raketen im gazastreifen getötet
eine eine c revolution die eigene
zivilbevölkerung als schutzschilde nuss
indem sie ihre eigenen raketenwerfer auf
schulen stellen
den waffenverstecken waffenarsenale und
sich in den dicht besiedelten regionen
im gazastreifen ihre medizinische
infrastruktur ihre terror infrastruktur
aufbauen
diese terror-organisation diese
islamistische terrorist und leichter
setzen mit israel
der einzige demokratie im nahen osten
juni als die pflicht zu erfüllen nach
internationalem recht und die eigene
zivilbevölkerung zu schützen vor eben
diesen terror das ist ein riesen
eigentor wer das tut und der sollte
erstens ein bisschen in die
geschichtsbücher gucken sollte sich
etwas besser informieren und sollte sich
fragen warum warum die realität so
verzerrt platziert und so verzerrt
wieder dargestellt wird und gucken ob er
nicht doch irgendein sehr stark
antiisraelisch das oder vielleicht sogar
englisches ressentiment sich versteckt
er kam es oft können sie da helfen
beispielsweise bei ihrem kollegen aus
der spd fraktion
ich will erst mal ein bisschen einordnen
und zwar finde ich wirklich klasse und
das sage ich hier ganz deutlich dass wir
hier mit jürgen trittin jemanden haben
der ausnahme bewegung kommt die früher
auch ein bisschen anders drauf war nach
den sechstagekrieg dem jom-kippur-krieg
war ja die berühmte des arafat tuch ein
accessoire das auf allen friedens demos
zu sehen war unterlag da gab es auf der
deutschen linken insgesamt eine eine
große neigung zur palästinensischen
sache die manchmal in anti israelische
haltung ungeschlagen ist bei den grünen
inzwischen nicht mehr der fall aber bei
hitze nicht wahr dass diese woche
spürbar der scheint immer noch in den
frühen 80er jahren verhaftet zu sein und
das ist falsch das ist einfach falsch
wir haben das ist fast so grebe das war
ein bisschen hut nehmen
was haben sie mit dem suchen sie alle
das gespräch mit ihm
wenn das das na ja klar ich meine der
mann ist fraktionsvorsitzender der der
sozialdemokratischen fraktion seiner die
regierung tragenden fraktionen und
natürlich redet man dann mit ihm und
versucht ihn davon zu überzeugen aber
das ist ganz tief drin das ist wirklich
tief ins gehört zu manchen politischen
biografien und manche greifen werden
klüger und und positionieren sich dann
in der bessere art und war auf eine
bessere art und weise
ich war davon ziemlich erschrocken ich
war auch von der äquidistanz den ersten
äußerungen auf twitter von heiko maas
erschrocken ein deutscher außenminister
der subtile genau das tut was versuche
gerade beschrieben hat nämlich beide
seiten zur deeskalation aufruft in der
situation wo die israelische
zivilbevölkerung mit einem raketen
terror überzogen wird das kann nicht die
äußerung eines deutschen außenministers
sein und insofern das ist etwas wo wir
auch unter demokraten immer noch dran
arbeiten müssen um es ganz klar zu sagen
und ein punkt der mir auch wichtig ist
auch für die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer
viele glauben vielleicht der gaza
streifen sei ein besetztes gebiet
tatsache ist seit 2005 sind ist israel
komplett zurückgezogen der traum war mal
aus gaza streifen ich weiß das klingt
total verrückt wenn man das heute sagt
aber 2005 war der traum dass hongkong am
mittelmeer daraus zu machen mit
tourismus mit industrie mit und so
weiter und dann ist die hamas an die
macht gekommen und seitdem ist es nicht
hongkong sondern nach raketenabschuss
basis mit der israelis terrorisiert
werden ohne dass dort eine israelische
besatzung stattfände
das muss man immer wieder sagen weil es
ein großer unterschied ist zum
westjordanland da wo die israelis sich
zurückgezogen haben da kommt die größte
gefahr zur zeit her und wenn das
israelische sicherheitskräfte ist dass
wir in deutschland da manchmal hingucken
und sagen wow das ist für uns schwer
nachzuvollziehen dann liegt es daran
dass wir neuen nachbarn haben die alle
mit friedlich mit uns zusammenleben und
israel keinen einzigen nachbarn hat der
wirklich friedlich mit ihm zusammenleben
will wenn wir mal von jordanien und im
kalten frieden da absehen und ich glaube
das müsste das muss man immer wieder
klar machen und verstehen israel ist ein
bedrohtes land die besatzung im
westjordanland ist ja übrigens auch das
ergebnis eines angriffs der arabischen
staaten auf israel und nicht etwa
umgekehrt das sind alles dinge die
manchmal mir ein bisschen untergehen in
den ganzen debatten die aber wirklich
dringend einfach mitgedacht werden
müssen wenn man die lage in der region
analysieren und verstehen will
herr franco wird eine frage noch an sie
bevor wir sie in die nacht entlassen
worauf stellen sie sich im moment ein
sie haben selbst gesagt sie sind auch
vater woraus stellen sie sich für die
nächsten tage für die nächsten wochen
ein auf ja möglicherweise hoffentlich
eine entspannung
also meine tochter
ich glaube im norden einfach nur damit
sie sicher recht
ich werde die nächsten zwei nächte im
heim sein um im fall von neuerlichen
angriffen zu helfen dort die leute in
sicherheit zu bringen ich denke gerade
vor allem von tag zu tag
ich hoffe natürlich dass diese
militärische auseinandersetzung bald
endet ich habe großes vertrauen in die
israelische armee und ich wünsche mir
aber noch viel mehr als ein schnelles
ende dauerhafte ruhe
ich hoffe dass die terroristen im
gazastreifen die terrororganisation
hamas islamische dschihad so empfindlich
getroffen werden dass wir in den
nächsten jahren nicht wieder einen punkt
und kommt dass wir hier unter
raketenbeschuss zu leiden haben und
selbstverständlich wünsche ich mir dass
dies möglichst ohne zivile opfer in gaza
passiert herr trittin ganz schnelle
schlussrunde was können wir was kann
deutschland was kann die eu ganz konkret
in dieser woche tun um die in
raketenbeschuss aus der seitens der
hamas aus dem gazastreifen zu beenden zu
stoppen ich glaube dass europa lange
zeit aus diesem konflikt weggeguckt hat
es ist ja nicht der erste konflikt
dieser 8 2008 2009 2012 2014
der status quo den wir dazwischen immer
wieder erlebt haben hat am ende nicht
getragen und deswegen wäre es jetzt an
der zeit für die europäische union für
deutschland sich wirklich auf eine echte
diplomatische initiative zur beendigung
der jetzigen gewalt aber auch zur hebung
der darunterliegenden konflikte dann
ignorieren hilft nicht ignorieren führt
in die eskalation der graf lambsdorff
wenn das schon alles ist nicht mehr
ignorieren sondern sich schlichtweg mal
engagieren
politisch innerhalb der eu dann geht es
voran ja besser als nix aber ich glaube
was wichtig ist wir können hier die
europäische union und deutschland nicht
gleichsetzen es gibt ein paar
traditionelle freunde israels in der eu
bulgarien dänemark österreich wir mit
der besonderen verantwortung es gibt
aber länder deren verbindungen in die
arabische welt viel enger sind und das
steht ganz vorne
frankreich deswegen ist mein appell an
die bundesregierung wir müssen mit
frankreich eine gemeinsame nahost linie
finden sonst werden wir nicht ernst
genommen und die amerikaner sind die
entscheidende westliche kraft und nur
europa das gemeinsam vorgeht wird auch
in amerika ernst genommen das muss man
hier in dieser deutlichkeit sagen
deswegen wünsche ich mir nach der
bundestagswahl spätestens eine echte
initiative für eine deutsch französische
verständigung über eine gemeinsame
nahost politik zurzeit haben wir keine
gemeinsame europäische politik makro
fährt sofort nach beirut wenn da ein
problem ist wir kümmern uns besonders um
israel berlin und paris müssen endlich
wieder miteinander reden das schweigen
insbesondere aus dem kanzleramt
das muss jetzt mal aufhören und man muss
endlich versuchen eine echte gemeinsame
europäische linie dazu finden kann
allerdings dann auch leider noch ein
bisschen dauern der bundestagswahl dann
die ganzen monate mögliche
koalitionsbildung und neuen kanzler oder
einer neuen kanzlerin da vergehen noch
viele viele monate herbst auf deutsch
danke sagen ganz kurz lassen sich das
noch sagen wenn sie fragen was können
wir jetzt unmittelbar tun ganz
unmittelbar
vertrauen wir mal den israelischen
streitkräften und der eiserne kuppel
dass sie so viele angriffe wie möglich
zurück schlagen und zu viele raketen wie
möglich abfangen können da kann niemand
von außen wirklich viele touren israel
ist ein starkes wenn auch ein kleines
land aber ein sehr starkes land die
innovationskraft ist enorm und diese
abwehrmechanismen damit mit diesem
eisernen sei seinen kumpel sind ja
wirklich beeindruckend da können wir
jetzt in dieser situation dieser sekunde
den israelis weniger beistehen als dass
sie sich selber helfen können wir
brauchen eine perspektive und die
perspektive lautet für mich deutschland
und frankreich müssen gemeinsam in der
region auftreten und bei einer suche
nach einer dauerhaften lösung finden
helfen denn das was herr trittin gerade
gesagt hat ist ja richtig alle paar
jahre gibt es einen großen konflikt und
noch nie ist ein status quo gefunden
worden
der mal länger getragen hätte damit eben
die familien von frau suchen
und herrn franco wird schon all den
anderen eben nicht ständig diese angst
haben müssen von neuen raketenangriffen
wäre aber so ein status quo der held
genau das was wir brauchen
letzte frage an herrn herrmann was tun
sie was tun sie mit dem
bundesinnenminister und vor allen dingen
auch mit ihren länderkollegen
innenministern dass es diese woche keine
weiteren demonstrationen gibt auf denen
beispielsweise tod israels und
bombardier tel aviv gerufen wird ja in
der tat wir müssen einerseits
außenpolitisch aktiv werden aber müssen
auch innenpolitisch verordnung auf den
deutschen straßen sorgen
wir haben auf jeden fall den schutz der
jüdischen und der israelischen
einrichtungen in unserem land massiv
verstärkte damit ist hier nicht zur
angriffe auf synagogen kommen kann oder
auf eine ein israelisches konsulat und
dergleichen und wir müssen konsequent
bei diesen demonstrationen mit der
polizei massiv präsent sein um deutlich
zu machen wir dulden es nicht wenn diese
demonstration ausufern und werden
konkret die straftäter auch sofort
dingfest machen das muss die klare
botschaft sein und das muss auch
vollzogen werden in den nächsten tag
dann kann sie alle dass sie teile ihres
arms heute mit uns hierbei bild
verbracht haben danke herzlich oliver
franco wird
ab ins bett jetzt einer hoffentlich
ruhige nacht wir wünschen ihnen alles
gute für die nächsten stunden die
nächsten tage auch ihnen freiwillig
natürlich herzlichen dank dafür dass sie
mit uns waren herr hamann hermsdorf herr
trittin danke dafür und ein letzter
blick geht einmal auf dieses bild mit
dem ich mich gerne von ihnen
verabschieden möchte es zeigt den
heutigen abend hier beim haus wir haben
gesprochen über flaggen die zumindest
versucht wurden anzuzünden am wochenende
hier in deutschland und wir haben ganz
bewusst ein zeichen gesetzt hier vor dem
springer hochhaus und sieht ein bisschen
wind hier an diesem abend die
israelische flagge und damit möchten wir
uns verabschieden und wir sehen uns
wieder am nächsten sonntag um dieselbe
zeit viertel vorziehen
[Musik]